[Musique]
bah tu te sers encore fait larguer papa
stopper là je suis crevé je peux poser
mais d'affaires et genre on en parle
après
[Musique]
chez rip un thé trouvé mon clap
tu ne sais pas dans quoi tu t'embarques
jeune fille ceux qui ont joué à ce jeu
en connaissent les dangers
non mais sérieux ne décolle pas et que
ça vraiment
[Musique]
ce
il
romain
tu penses vraiment
ok qu'est ce que je fous là pardon pour
avoir appelé ma fille aînée jamais la
prévenir quand tu as une retard la
condamnation et la mort par décapitation
est ce que je suis désolé d'en vraiment
vous savez pas faire sa déco n'est pas
prouvé que même été complètement malade
on a dit que c'était terminé
peut-être moi tranquille maintenant
[Musique]
maman disait toujours la vie c'est comme
une boîte de chocolats mais en fait tu
laisses tomber tu as l'air con je te
préférable à temps qui courent avec ce
truc là montrons ce que tu fais montre
non ou alors avec des chaussures au
moins parce que je vienne nettoyer oui
alors justement en parlant nettoyage
parlons-en parce que votre fille là un
[Musique]
passage en temps réel façon personne ne
peut te plairait à louey toi moi
n'importe qui personnes oeuvrent à brécy
fort qu'elle avait c'était vraiment way
chérie si tu pouvais me laisser orthez
histoire ça serait cool
salut romain mais de toute façon je me
suis toujours emmerdé avec toi dommage
que j'ai pas trouvé ça plus tôt j'aurais
pu te rendre sexy
là c'est bien
un super héros juste pour moi
au cinéma
[Musique]
thériault avec tant qu'il n'est pas
utilisé tu sais quoi je crois que c'est
pas une bonne idée
maintenant on attend attend et on est
d'accord c'était totalement gratuit là
on est réflexe de défense vas-y tu peux
rentrer chez toi monsieur manar a pas
s'arrêter maintenant
récemment dans ce truc pense à celui qui
a que toi qui peux utiliser je crois que
c'est parce qu'il a manqué marqué je me
permets voilà conservatoire s'amuser à 2
c'est à dire un film de super héros
j'aide mes yeux rivés
[Musique]
mais on pourra pas dire qu'on n'a pas
profité de l'avion
c'est pas fini à tanger une idée les
mythes et tuba vente
[Musique]
[Rires]
you les petits chats un petit bout pour
te dire que le 25 mai à 20h55 sur kobe
plus il y aura golden moustache fait son
cinéma et que ce sera trop trop bien
maintenant il y aura des quoi alors il y
aura des sketches inédits il y aura des
parodies des bandes allons aider le
meilleur de défauts micro et jordi et
martin évidemment parce que sur les
arbres c'est pas parce qu'on est devenu
speakerine du comedy plus à sa part
encore pas encore
[Musique]